we faked our own documents to pass
identity verification we won't use the
results of this experiment to cause any
harm our goal is to demonstrate whether
modern Technologies sufficiently protect
us and our identities online first we
select country on a special site as well
as age and gender now we click create
fake ID yeah very convenient for
scammers don't quite like this name yep
then we use an artificial face and now
we need to preserve the holographic
security film but
[Music]
there's one more important detail and
that's the so-called mrz or machine
readable Zone mrz can be scanned either
through photo or video or through
specially built scanners we just tried
to make it look real new identity done
but
it didn't work why
see the real experiment with services in
our long video down below stay real